get an update now from Thailand what
could be the final rescue operation has
resumed with four boys and their
football coach remaining trapped
underground in the caves the authorities
say they are aiming to bring them all
out to safety today and we can speak to
our correspondent Sally Lockwood who's
in chiang rai and by definition sally if
you're trying to get five people out
rather than four in the two previous
successful rescue attempts this is going
to be even more nerve-racking
nerve-racking yes and one would think
more lengthy however rescue teams have
done very well in the last two days as
we've seen yesterday they improved their
time their rescue time by two hours it
took them nine hours to rescue the four
boys yesterday instead of the eleven
hours the day before so they are
obviously becoming more familiar with
what's involved and more confident
because they've been so successful so
far which is obviously buoyed everyone
here everyone who's been waiting for
this news anxiously not least the
families but the world is watching and
willing this to be a happy ending and so
far it's looking really good and we've
been getting reports in the last few
moments that the ninth boy has been
rescued we are awaiting confirmation on
this but we've been told by people here
on the ground we've been heading up to
the cave entrance that the night boy has
been rescued and we are hoping to see an
ambulance in the next 45 minutes around
five o'clock local time
it's obviously we have to be very
careful not to celebrate prematurely
here because the boys are going through
such an extraordinary ordeal in this
evacuation it's a full kilometer
evacuation from the shelter where
they've been from the ledge where
they've been sheltering for the last 17
nights now and it involves them having
to dive for parts of this escape on
their own and of course as we know these
boys had never dived before most of them
didn't swim and the expert divers who
are here carrying out this rescue say
it's one of the most challenging dives
they've ever done which is why this is
in such worrying and precarious and
dangerous situation however so far
miraculously eight boys have not only
managed to escape underwater with the
help of the Thai Navy SEALs and these
incredible rescue teams and they're also
doing well we've had an update from
medics today that they're in good health
on the whole and in good spirits so so
far so good we're hoping for a Knight's
Rescue to confirm very shortly and we're
hoping of course to bring you good news
by the end of the day